[Music]
alright let's get started so today's
goal is to like build a chat for small
chat board that like shows what you can
do machine learning and how you can
train a chat board just using machine
learning and not ruin a system so we're
going to do this with Raza and indigo
and rather Korra but first a bit of a
motivations like why do we actually want
to build a chat board so here's an
example conversation the user talking to
a bank like a bank chat board and he
tells the chat father he just moved
right so the bank has the address stored
and so they want to update the address
right so they want to keep that on file
and the user just provides a partial
address and about suggests it's in New
York right which is not correct the user
thinks or doesn't think he lives in San
Francisco and he corrects that answer
from the board and from that interaction
you can see that even this like simple
interaction of like filling like one
form filled with a new address can be
quite different between users right so
one user might write that address right
there
completely correct in one message other
users might use multiple messages only
put the street there only put the city
there or like I don't know miss
misspelled something right and so you
need a chat pod that actually is able to
handle like these different users and
this different dialogue flows and what
we see here is that conversation I will
dramatically change how users interact
with you because it's quite different
from an app UI or from a back page
because here the user defines how the
conversation continues right in your app
or on your web page you define the
layout you define the menus right so and
this way with a chat pod the user decide
decides what happens next and the bots
react
and if the user provides different
inputs he will follow a different flow
and the goal is to build a small example
that shows that different user inputs
can actually influence the bot and how
that translates into machine learning
model that we're gonna use Raza it's an
open source framework so it's part it's
two parts Raza NAU and R as a core and
I'm gonna explain in quite some detail
what they are about so there's a lot of
machine learning going on there in both
parts and we'll see how they connect and
how they like form a bot when combined
there a lot of other solutions as well
but we were like one of the early major
open source solutions that do dialog
handling all right so here's a major and
here's a high-level overview over the
solutions so the user message comes in
what's the weather like tomorrow this
usually goes through connector right
could be Facebook could be whatsapp or
just a chat window on your web page and
that message then gets like forwarded to
your input module this is so-called NAU
right so you want to understand the
message of the user
it's just typed text and now we want to
extract information from that what does
the user mean with that message which
information is part of that message this
is what we call input modules then we
have our dialog management here which we
call a brain so the brain gets all the
structured input from the NAU and is
connected to the backend databases and
api's writes is able to fetch more
informations from the web like whether
api's or your back-end or database and
combine that information with the dialog
it's having with the user and the third
part our output mob notes right so when
we've found the answer that we want to
return to the user we still need to
create some text for the user to
understand so because from api's we
usually get structure information
so now we need to convert that into
sentences again that the user can you
can understand and in our example it
might be it will be sunny and 20 degrees
after the user asked what's the weather
like tomorrow and that information
obviously required us to call an API to
get the sunny and 20 degrees it required
us to figure out that there's tomorrow
in there and as you might see we didn't
ask for a location in that sentence so
we either got it for GPS or we have it
from a past conversation or we got it
from the database because it's the usual
location of the user but you could
imagine that for new users we don't know
the location so the dialogue would go
into a different direction here a couple
of alternatives right so this dialogue
flow which is a hosted solution from
from Google they do mostly annal you and
a bit of rule base dialogue handling so
you can do some form filling and I think
they called fulfillments are calling
api's and then there's with a I which is
from Facebook and then there's Lois
which is the last one and that one is
from Microsoft
all of these are hosted solutions to
kind of have UI and all that online we
focus on a bit of a different area so
why would you want to choose Raza or
with these hosted solutions
it runs locally right so you can just
spin it up locally you have all the
control over over your instance and you
can also deploy it anywhere right you
can run it locally and run it in a cloud
you can run 100 instances of it in
parallel to scale your load and most
importantly you own your data right so
none of your data is like get sent to
central server and stored the Google
headquarters which is especially
important for like sensitive data like
health information your banking
information and you know that's a
unattackable right so you can actually
create your own machine learning models
we provided a couple of them we provide
dialogue models we provide models for
NAU but in the end if you
side ok this model I outgrew that model
I have a lot of data I can analyze it
and I do have some insights into what
might work better you can just create
your own models and plug them into Raza
and your system will still work using
your own models so you can like further
improve down the road when you have
collected more and more data all right
couple words about me I'm sorry I
studied computer science in Germany and
then I went on to find the consultancy
focusing on image and text analysis
called scalable mites and then like my
interests in text and messages and
analysis brought me to the rather team
where I'm now leading the open-source
development so all the parts we're going
to see there are the core as an
interview that are open source and key
to reading development there and yeah if
you have any questions about that right
now or later or when you try it out at
home just let me know shoot me a mail or
we have a get to channel as well so if
you need any support just let me know
yeah that's about me but I also want to
get an impression of you guys so who of
you has already trained a machine
learning model oh yes there's a bad one
because there was talking about that and
so who you has worked with net language
processing before like text processing
core who of you has already built a chat
board let's get it thin well if you have
users rather that's good
alright because now I can explain to
everyone and that's our goal right so we
want to build a bot there's able to
understand natural language in a certain
domain and that can handle certain types
of user input here's a quick road map of
how we going to do that so first we will
focus on natural language understanding
so as I said getting user messages in
and transforming them into structured
output some Theory there and then we're
gonna code a bit
then we're gonna have a look at dialogue
handling again some theory some coding
and at the end I also want to have a
look at some research we're currently
doing so just telling you about like
different topics different areas we're
currently looking into improving models
and there's probably some time at the
end for questions but if you have
questions in the meantime just let me
know where is raise your hand and
involve check out them right away okay
quick setup so as I said we're gonna use
not true there's an age Dupuy the
notebooks and 3:6 so you should have
that installed if you want to run it
locally otherwise I'm gonna run it here
as well you could just watch me as well
but it's also fun to try locally and
play around with the bots you're
creating and I said that's your same
honest here alright so let's take a look
under the hood of the natural language
understanding right so our goal is to
create structured data so this is
another example user says I have a new
address it's 709 King Street in San
Francisco and there's two things we want
to know first what a super user trying
to tell us in general which in this case
is address change alright so this is the
overall intent of the message could be a
greeting as well could be a goodbye
could be I want some information about
my account there's a lot of different
categories but in this case it would be
address change and once we found that
intent we still need some additional
information to change the address in
that case right these couple words 709
King Street San Francisco that tell us
the address of the user to actually
change our data in the database and one
step further we not only need to extract
their information we also need to
normalize it especially in from
important for these addresses or for
days or numbers you don't want to have
the word three or four as a text but you
usually want to have that as a number
when you want to handle that in code or
write that into any database and so
that's one big part as well let's take a
look at how that works we're going to
look at the intent classification first
so our user input is now what's the
weather like tomorrow and hits our net
for language understanding component and
gets now classified then to do so we
first vectorize our input sentence so we
have two different words what's the
weather like tomorrow each word has a
vector what we'll take a look at that
later and see how Spacey provides these
pre trained word vectors and then you
need to combine these word vectors in
this into a sentence representation my
same vector I don't know 300 dimensional
and that worked vector representation of
the whole sentence is then fed into an
intent classifier right simplest case
it's just an SVM that you run and train
on a cap of classes and in this case our
output will then be request better and
here's a really really simple approach
to get a sentence representation so we
have our message we have our bag of
words right so we split the sentence
into its tokens so simplest way is to
split on whitespace but as you can see
even with the Watts
you need to put in some logic there but
it's kind of 99% solved and then you
have your bag of words and you look up
the vector for each of that word of
these words and then you can just
combine them with an average alright
this is so-called bag of roots approach
order doesn't matter right so if we
reorder the words in the sentence the
model doesn't care which also brings us
to downside of that model because of
course some meaning gets lost in that
process but for simple chatbots that's
usually fine but once you've collected
more data
should probably use a more advanced
model and then we can feed that into our
SVM and start our classification in that
case we have one of the five classes a
greet goodbye thank you request weather
and confirm and as you can see the
classifier will have will put every
message into one of these buckets
all right so every incoming messages
either greet or one of the other four
right if we put in I want a pizza apple
syllable one of these five all right so
this is something you need to keep in
mind that the bot has a limited view of
the world
if especially if you use that approach
there are other approaches but that one
is particularly good when you get
started because it's a simple model it's
an SVM it doesn't be too much training
data to like do reasonably well on a
small data set all right let's take a
quick look at the entity extraction as
well so that's a bit more complicated
but very similar so we tokenized the
sentence as well again on white space
for example and then we use a part of
speech tagger that is not necessary but
provides some useful information so in
that case we would tag what is it were
what is the adjective or how the
dependencies look between the words
which gives us some more information
about the structure of the sentence that
we can later use for classification then
we have a chunker to like form larger
chunks of words for that sentence that's
not really necessary but for the one
with the address right we have that
address which is multiple tokens but one
chunk and then we do our named entity
recognition and extraction in our
example we would have the input what's
the but I like tomorrow and the output
would be okay the value is tomorrow and
the entity type we extracted is a date
as you can see we still have normalized
that so it still tomorrow and probably
would want to
get that into a proper eyes a date he's
a possible model you could use right so
we're kind of get a burrito in the
secondary small they're two entities
here cous identification and they're
multiple ways to do this classification
task alright as I said we first
tokenized the the message and then we
can for example use two classifiers
first one just saying okay is this token
an entity and a second one okay for the
ones where we found out there is an
entity here which type of entity is it
we could do it that way and thus work
okay not really well better is a direct
structured prediction where you go
through the sentence look at each token
after one another and the prediction of
the current token is influenced by the
surrounding words right because it's
more likely in our street case we're in
the middle word maybe San Francisco is
tagged with a city that the surrounding
token is an address all right so the
words influence each other and using for
example a conditional random field as we
do in Raza is quite a good solution or
one good solution that works with a few
data samples as I said you can then
expand that and use for example deep
learning models embedding character
bearings to dem train
DNA our models alright that's code um so
here is what we want to build it's
quickly little thing so the user says
hello but answers hello and then ask
okay how are you in this case as you can
see the Facebook UI can even provide
couple of buttons but you can actually
write whatever you want that's the idea
and then the bot responds with an answer
in the case where you are sad but tried
to lighten your mood and in the case
where you are already feeling grade the
bot is doing something else and this is
what I mean with like forking the
conversation right
depending on the user input we're gonna
do different things it's a really simple
example but as you can imagine this is
how it works for the address case as
well but restricts the domain a bit and
makes it a bit easier for us to code in
such a limited time all right so let's
jump into that ipython notebook here we
go okay that's not so all of that okay
all right so I'm just gonna step through
these different cells there's a bit of
code that's already in there which is
mostly setup code I should make it
bigger probably and it's good I guess
so first yeah we're gonna set up my flip
and a bit of logging and a small helpful
that allows us to print it's a bit
easier and then there's this block of
setup so it actually installs three
packages rather core right here
razza nau and it's part of Raza and you
would install Spacey as well so yeah I'm
gonna run that as well but I actually
have that installed so it shouldn't
actually do anything but download the
model so it takes a minute yeah you can
either run it here in the ipython or you
can also run these commands on the
command line in your environment
installing like these dependencies that
Spacely model we're going to use is
trained on a web crawl right so couple
webpages that got dumped into a large
file as well as well as I think
telephone records from telephone
companies which is pretty cool for us
because they are quite relevant for the
chat domain because short of total
messages spoken and not written
and yeah and I don't think the Wikipedia
isn't part of that one but yeah this is
quite a solid model space he actually
provides a couple of them so there's a
small one the medium one a large one for
chatbot development you should always at
least use the medium one if you want to
use Spacey because the small one does
behave a bit strange because it doesn't
actually store route vectors but
actually uses some similarity to figure
out vectors which doesn't work very well
for for this use case looks better for
larger larger documents so that's why
we're going to use that medium mauler
yeah
okay
getting close yeah
we also provide a new pipeline in Raza
and you that doesn't actually use Spacey
but use and it uses a different approach
to divert vectors so there you don't
need like these pre-trained with vector
models but in our case because we do
have quite a small data set it's better
to use these pre trained word vectors
then to start from scratch who of you
already knows about word vectors not
that I'm like talking about something
that no one okay that's good so kind of
you have your your bag of words all the
words you know and you assign a word
back to each of them and that word
vector should somehow capture the
meaning of that word so just like a
rough explanation of how they work but
yeah there's a lot of book boys about
that so what are you going to do next is
just test that our installation is as I
expected it to be and you should have
rather and you twelve and rather core
nine and that Spacely model should load
properly right now like this looking
good we also need graph is and the pie
graph this package for some graph we're
gonna plot later if that doesn't work on
your local machine it's not don't worry
about that I'll show the graph here as
well and you can install it later so
cool
mm yeah okay that's good all right so
let's start like creating training data
for our model um so how this works in
Raza is you have a file and then you put
in the intense you want like in this
case I want the intent Greek and now I
need to specify examples for that right
so one example could be high and other
one could be hello then we could have
like good morning or a good day or a
good evening or howdy right you can't
adjust then we need a goodbye as well so
that our user our button knows when to
say goodbye yeah it's always sometimes
sometimes also good to include some
spelling mistakes because you know users
are going to do that as I said rozzers
module are stuff what you could do as
well as plug in some component before
hours a telling you that actually does
some spell checking to make some of the
models more robust against like these
typing errors I'm a bit lazy so I'm just
gonna cuff me a couple of them all right
so as you can see still greet and
goodbye is too intense then I added some
more examples for mood affirm so when
the user says yes or indeed and kind of
affirms the action of the bot and then
some some examples for deny so if the
user like denies what the board is doing
and then for our mood pod where we want
to like ask the user how he's doing we
also need some examples for for
utterances that tell us like the mood of
the user so we have two categories mood
great and food unhappy my day was
horrible I'm sad um so yeah I hope your
day is more like the examples of mood
great
and we're gonna write them to file and
this file is then gonna use for the
training we're gonna modify that later
as well but this is I our initial yeah
that's part of notebook yeah so it's a
pretty easy way to write a variable to
file yeah yeah I think it's built-in I
haven't been spoke anything hopefully
yes it's pretty so we need all the data
and files because that's usually how you
run these these trainings the idea being
that you collect more and more data over
time time stored in the database or on
disk and then loaded in the script we
provide a couple scripts to really train
the models on the command line but in
our example we're not going to do it but
we're actually gonna do it in Python
code but you can also yeah there's
tutors on the documentation so you can
find that the links are in the slides as
well you can find documentation under
NAU Durazo calm and there's a couple
examples that show you how to train them
all so even without Python um to get
started real quick but that's that we're
gonna do the piping because it's cool
all right
as I said Raza and you uses components
to do the classifications so we do have
different components for different tasks
that allow us to like exchange them in
our system and replace them with like
better components for our task at hand
we do have one component for a space see
here their loads are a spacey language
model so this kind of goes loads the
language file puts all of the vectors
into memory and then when a message is
coming in assigns these vectors onto our
message and we have tokenizer spacey
spacey also provides tokenization I
don't want to have that engine yet then
we have our intent feature Iser Spacey's
this is doing the mapping from one word
to one vector
and from a couple of words their
sentence into one vector for that
sentence so there's our intent feature
isn't and at the end we have our intent
as far as I learn so in this example
it's an SVM in that class but yeah you
can replace it with any other classifier
from from SK learn to that you want to
try out all right so let's store that in
the configuration file as well
oh yeah that's a quick look at how these
components work so they get the context
which is kind of the training data then
the first components in the pipeline
gets created and initialized and the
second component in the pipeline gets
created and initialized in the last
component so on and once all component
got created they get trained after one
another and this allows us to like
really push data from one component to
another right so one component that
comes later in the pipeline can use the
information component previous and the
pipeline provides which you usually want
if you like to create these
vectorization sort organizations and
then all of them get persisted so this
kind of the training lifecycle but the
same happens when we actually handle
messages there is a similar flow all
right so let's actually train our model
so we have we've created our
configuration we've created our hours
training data yep the tokens so tokens
is really just single words all right so
if you have a sentence exactly spitting
on whitespace you usually get most of
the tokens but then again you sometimes
have like what's like with what and an
extra fast don't have whitespace they
are still two two tokens but yeah
spitting on whitespace is kind of a good
approximation in the beginning but you
can train to be better
you know so yeah one powered
tokenization and then assigning each of
these tokens its vector it's kind of
what space he does okay let's take a
look at the training code so it's quite
quite simple so we load our data which
is like the intends and examples for
fitting into the file then we create our
trainer based on our configuration so
it's creating like this pipeline up here
and then we can actually train them all
and we'll get back an interpreter we can
actually use to pass messages and
because we need to use it later on with
our dialogue model we also going to
persist that to the models and a new
folder now as you can see is that we
have six distinct intends in our in our
domain a couple examples and no entities
right now so as you've seen I didn't add
any entities yet we're gonna try that
out in a minute
and then one after one component after
another gets trained and persisted to
disk
okay what about entities um that's a
good question in my notebook
so for intense you usually don't need
too much training data for a simple
domains where the intents are quite
different like goodbye and hello
words are quite different so it's quite
easy for the model to pick up different
intents for entities it's a bit harder
so usually you need a bit more training
data that's why this example doesn't use
any entities later and but we're still
gonna try to add some entity recognition
here so hey I am tongue hello there I am
Thomas and usually how you would enter
Tait entities in Raza is just writing it
like that all right so the the entity
value in brackets and then we're gonna
annotate that I call
we don't have any entity recognition
component in here I can just add all of
these components kind of come with Raza
and you when you install that possess ad
can always write your own ones but so
yeah the entity is always defined in
these samples right because you want to
detect it in the samples but it's not
the entity types a person is not bound
to greet so you can still recognize a
person down here in a goodbye example
obviously if the model has never seen
that in a goodbye example and usually
won't pick that up but entities and
intends are kind of separate concepts
like there's like not this concept of
these are the five entities that belong
to this intent to similar that so they
kind of separate so kind of and every
entity type can occur in every intent I
mean you should label as across intense
so it's better to label it across
intense than just in one intent because
what the model will pick up a sentence
structure right so it will also
recognize values it has never seen
during training so for in this case at
some point if we have enough training
data it will pick up other names that we
haven't seen in training and to do that
it needs to like recognize the sentence
structure and for this to happen you
should like provide different sentence
structures and that means you should put
it into different intents because the
entities usually occur in different
places in a different intense also make
sense
yeah what so we could for example say
bye from future right yeah okay all
right so I'm gonna add one component
here that actually does the intent
recognition that's actually a pre
trained component so it's not training
on that data because as I said we do you
need a bit more training data and not
just three examples for entity
recognition so usually you need I don't
know around 50 or 100 samples to like
really get like a stable model there and
this way we're gonna use the pre trained
model Dupree trained Spacey NER model I
said just out of that through the
configuration we could just try it again
right so now we do have one entity here
and three examples and let's see how the
training goes all right stop pretty
quick as you can see now we've edit and
yes Pacey here as well so that's now
part of our pipeline as well I'm not
actually going to use this name part of
the model but for the sake of showing
intense entities that's good alright so
in this step we can actually try them
all out right so now that we've trained
it we can actually shoot messages at it
and just play around with it and see how
it performs as you can see is doing
quite well for that message that I hope
does not belong to the training data but
can also shoot hello there is still a
greeting so quite good yeah oh come on
that's wrong
this probably wrong because it doesn't
have a good vector in the English
language I guess right and the in the
corpus it's trained on it probably does
not have an assigned weight vector so it
gets represented as all zero
which is kind of a bad input for our
machine learning model because it's just
one road which has all zeros so the
whole sentence has all zeros so there's
not a lot of input for the model to pick
up yep let's put in pizza it's a
greeting right as I said I don't know
have I and it's good boy right as I said
it will it will assign all of these
messages to one of the intents we have
and this is something you need to keep
in mind when you handle messages there
different ways to get around that but it
is actually quite a hard problem what
you can do is you can train models that
I just trained to recognize the case
this message part of my domain or is it
not but actually even that gets tricky
quite quickly so for example let's
imagine you have an fhq bot right you
what answers questions and then there's
certain questions the bot is not able to
answer that a kind of out of scope
differentiating between these questions
is kind of hard and very harder than
differentiating between Pizza Hawaii and
I'm great and I'm good right so that
that would be rather easy to pick out
but yeah interval is not not an easy
problem but the more data we have the
more we hope that we at least get low
probabilities and low confidence scores
for these messages yeah none
oh you mean kind of kind of no hmm kind
of providing examples for that yeah that
that works and you kind of train your
model on your domain as well as a couple
examples that are out of the main yeah
as I said for these simple examples that
will work but then again usually the
messages that are in your domain how
smaller than the ones that are out of
domain and then you run into issues with
class imbalances stuff like that
all right so yeah the parts that are out
if it domain a way larger than it once
you usually want to handle yeah but this
is one good solution that works well for
for pods because something that we
usually advise as well um don't design
for a user that wants to break your bot
right if they want to write pizza to
your board that's doing banking then
they won't probably want to break it you
can't handle some of these cases but you
probably cannot handle all of them but
you should do some effort to have a look
nevertheless alright so our example
Hawaii we actually can see that any our
space in action so as I said it's a pre
trained model and we can have a quick
look at the entities it recognizes so
it's trained and persons on
organizations on locations on countries
and time and date itself so kind of a
lot of pre train entities that usually
need and some and a lot of the domains
and it I think is trained on like large
corpora I think one note5 yeah so it's
the same same corporate language mullahs
trained on yeah
if you need these entities you should
reuse them and once you've collected
enough data and you can start training
and refining them maybe you have names
in your country that's basically doesn't
recognize in the model it's trained on
and then you can refine that model all
right
I'm Tom writes and my name gets like
recognized as a person here as well so
that works quite well all right yeah now
that we've trained our model of played
around with it a bit but we actually
want to see how it does in a
classification and we do provide a
couple tools there as well there's a
simple script to you that runs through a
file get collects the predictions
compares them and then give some
evaluation oh yeah that's right
give some in evaluation about how good
the model performs in that case as you
can see I just used the training data
we've defined up there but you can like
define or you should define test data
you should not test on your training
data as you probably all know and if you
don't define any test data then you get
really good results like that one for
our really simple model and what we can
do real quick we can for example what's
easy maybe that one would affirm I agree
with you that sounds good
like that noise so create a bit of a
different training data set and then we
can still evaluate on that and see how
our firm intent performs on a couple
different sentences we haven't seen
during training I don't know I haven't
tried it before
hopefully works not too bad
but I said well that's actually not too
bad for him right no that's too bad it's
bad yeah so as you can see it's chained
on like four samples and you need very
more data to likely create a good mole
there so in the model we use for entity
recognition we don't actually used any
word vectors so it's trained on patterns
so it looks as first characters is the
it's the stream upper case lower case
does it contain numbers and then it
looks at the surrounding tokens so it's
kind of an Engram model yeah that's
looking at the word vectors and all of
them now it's actually using the word
vector for Tom which probably doesn't
have a good vector in that case so it
will be zero yeah um both experimented
with replacing like no and entities with
other tokens and it can definitely
provide some improvement yeah it depends
a bit on what you want to depend on
right so either you can make your entity
recognition dependent on your intent
classification meaning that let's say we
recognize the intent is greeting then
the probability of finding a name is
probably higher than in a good by 1/10
all right so we can influence our entity
recognition on the other hand if we know
there's a name in there greeting is also
likely err right um so it's kind of a
hand and egg problem and yeah we were
trying to get around
all right let's get our original
training data bat back cool the
evaluation so yeah it doesn't look too
good which is usually a good sign that
you need a bit more training data as I
said it looks at the word vectors and if
there are a lot of words in there that
the model hasn't seen during training
then it doesn't have a signal to pick up
yeah and we can also see the in entity
evaluation of that person model and as
you can see performs quite well and as I
said it doesn't get trained all the data
I provided it just gets evaluated on
that because it's a pre trained model so
it doesn't actually look at the data
during training all right so that's let
me just quickly check yep
looking good are there any questions
like concerning I know you training the
model
I mean basically does provide some good
language models for the major languages
English German Spanish French they work
pretty well I think Dutch is in there as
well it's quite good but then again you
can also use fast X vector for example
you can load them with Spacey you can
also write a known component that those
indirectly we've also created a
component that doesn't need any word
vectors at all which that kind of solves
that language problem to some extent
because as I said you still need
tokenization
and that can be quite language dependent
so yeah you can like get around that
problem a bit but in the end the more
you have you should recreate your own
divert vectors even if you use like
these pre-trained good vectors for the
English language as I said they are
trained on use copper are and and web
cross so they are from a different
domain than we are using them on so they
contain a lot of words that we usually
don't use in chaps and they are missing
a lot of words that are used in chats
and so the best way is to collect data
and then at some point really fine-tune
your model train your language model
spacing or with any other light library
it's not not space dependent all right
then let's jump back and take a quick
look at the dialog handling but before
that and now I need Thomas because I
need to get you awake again at least I'm
in a food coma and I need your full
attention for the dialogue part because
it's a bit of heavy machine learning and
so we're gonna do a quick wake up game
and have three minutes of fun and Thomas
is gonna help me with that
and I need all of you to stand out so
just put your laptops on your on your
chair and just get up get a good stand
and find a partner actually usually the
one next to you hopefully I pick Thomas
all right it's a quick game I hope
everyone has a partner
[Music]
looks good
okay everyone has exactly four movements
right hands up
sounds good hands down all right hands
left and that's right yeah it's a bit
weird for for you and I sir I mean you
get you get the idea you can choose them
at random but between each of your
movements you just slap your a perm
blacks right so it's like that you can
do it as alright it looks weird if I do
it alone so hands up alright you can
find your own rhythm right okay that was
easy so now now with your partner we do
it in the same rhythm right yeah first
up okay this is man okay same rule we
don't need to do the same thing you do
your stuff don't look at me okay and now
one second you're missing the brain part
if right everyone does it at random if
you and your partner do the same stuff
you just give him a high five right so
mm-hmm but if we don't do the same stuff
we don't high five right okay whatever
we do okay all right stop what I say so
all right now you can do whatever you
want
if you do the same stuff okay
left yeah yeah all right if you like to
change you can speed it up okay guys
thank you so much
thanks Thomas okay I hope everyone got
his blood flowing again
okay I hope everyone is like awake again
at least awake hopefully listening now
and now we're going to look at the
dialer can link so why do we actually
need dialog handling and it's like one
of the best images we've seen so why do
we want I locate link chat boards or do
we want them sorry I don't understand I
say you do really need context to handle
dialogues we can create simple BOTS that
just answer fhq questions and like one
interaction use a post a message you
answer is a per semester to answer but
if you don't take any context into
account your BOTS will seem dumped at
some point and it's just not a lot of
fun and we want to avoid state machines
I'll show you in a second why they can
be good starter but it's hard to
maintain and them over time and it's
hard to extend them over time we don't
want to reinforcement use reinforcement
learning right now because you need a
lot of data there we've tried it and
usually for the systems that chat bots
are designed for you don't have enough
data for them to properly train a
reinforcement learning client so yeah
what you could do is you could write
your own client that kind of simulates a
Chad user but then again what is the
purpose of that and then you need to
find probably our function so be let's
avoid there for now and both will use
deep learning model and recurrent neural
network so what we want to provide some
solution that works so why machine
learning so this is simple graph right
so user input could be goodbye it could
be greed and then but does one action
and the conversation is kind of over
right and the next user input next bot
actions are about actions are always
these bubbles and these blue boxes
already intense as you can see these are
really short conversations and very
simple but once you've started with that
system and then you collect more and
more data and see how users use you
bought it kind of ends up in that so you
have a lot of different dialogue
parce a lot of different actions and
they kind of go all over the place
and as you can see creating that as the
state machine is kind of heart and yeah
this is really simple but it's not not a
hard word and I think it has like one or
two use cases so one of two things it
can do yeah
all right so how are we going to do to
dialogue handling so this case he's a
message comes in right we got our
intense we got our entities let's say we
figure that out we've trained a good
model not the one we just had but really
good one that recognizes and intense and
entities and now we're going to combine
it with some state and that state is
formed by the previous bot action as
well as the past dialogue and we're
going to predict the next section so
that's pretty easy
and the magic actually happens in there
you go signs so that is our classifier
that's our SVM our recurrent neural
network or whatever classify you want to
use and then the magic continues right
so we update our internal states based
on that past action and the new message
that we just handled and we can create
our response for our bot so in that case
it will be sunny in 20 degrees and
probably in that case this action we
just chose called some API got some
result in the back back end and then
created this response from all of that
input and then again next user message
gets received by the bot we are combined
it with the object it's a flaky next
section all right so this is the
high-level view let's dive into the
machine learning so rather than you
there's some intent classification into
entity extraction well we do have our
recruiting tool at work here in the
middle that receives different types of
input right it receives the intent
classification resolves and receives
entity extraction resolves it receives
results from API calls so if you fetch
the weather API that API might return
I don't know load that location or I'm
currently unavailable and all of these
results should influence the prediction
of the next section of the port right if
the API is not available probably want
to tell that the user that right
currently there's no weather it's a big
and that model receives that data for
every user message right so if we want
to predict the next section we don't
only look at the current state but also
we look at all the past states all right
so the previous message of the user gets
fed into this model first and then our
current state is get fed into our Ellis
TM so this is why it's a recurrent
neural network model it does not only
handle one input but multiple inputs
after one another which kind of have an
relationship between them and usually
what's implemented afterwards is an
action mask so sometimes you do have
actions that require for example
authentications so for example if your
user can change the address with your
pods you only want to allow that for
users that actually are customers of
your bank and to really make sure your
bot never predict something that it
should not execute you do have your
extra masks and some conditions there
and so this was described in the
original paper we have not implemented
that in a rather yet because we didn't
need it yet and then usually renormalize
right so because you've executed a
couple actions so to like allow your
action predictions to sum up to one
again you just renormalize and then you
have probabilities for all actions that
are possible I just choose choose the
most likely one when you use the bots
and doing training you just sample from
that distribution and then that creates
your next action right which could
either be an API call it can be user
utterance about assurance and depending
on the type it will then return a
message here one important part is that
this loop here right so this prediction
loop between the model here and an
action that gets executed
down here can be repeated multiple times
so it's not always one user input and
one bot action it can always it can also
be one user input five bot actions and
then we wait for the next user input
this allows you to make your bot actions
very small and then compose them in
different dialogues in the way you want
them so for example in our example there
is probably one action that fetches the
data from the API and the second action
that actually creates to use outruns so
in that case we would have two actions
actually it's a it's free because the
last action we predict this action
listen so this is kind of a special
action once we predict that we wait for
the next user input so this is kind of
our sign that tells us okay stop the
prediction for now wait for the next
user input any questions yeah it is
trained on real conversations yeah I'll
show you how we're going to create a
training data we're going to create it
by hand and not like try it on real
dialogues because we have not collected
them yet but the idea really is that you
create your initial version of the bot
put it online and then collect more and
more dialogues alright creating this
kind of improvement loop right
collecting more and more data improving
the board retraining it putting it
online so this this is the whole idea
and this is like the major benefit of
using these trained models instead of
food systems right because you can base
your new models on on training data you
collect from your users and this is why
it's really valuable that you actually
own your own data all right that's good
yeah let me get to that notebook again
okay writing story so as we said we do
need a couple dialogues that our bot is
trained on
and there's different ways to create
like these initial stories are about a
strain on I'll show you one way and
after that once we're done I'll show you
quickly another way to create them we do
have a special format but for for
creating these stories but it's really
simple so every story has a title for us
humans to later understand what they
mean this is usually only used in
initial data generation so when you
generate your data from user
conversations they don't have title so
this is just like a simple simple greed
all right so in this case the user says
greet so this is the intent of the user
message remember we already extracted
that using our NLU and then we tell our
bot to do our greed and that's about it
alright so it's this is the incoming
message then we want our bot to predict
utter greet and the next action it
predicts afterward what is action listen
and that's this is the whole interaction
it stuff let's try and see if that works
and then we'll extend that we do need a
so called to my domain file as well so
this define it defines out the scope of
the bot it contains all the intense its
handle it handles right so these are the
intense we trained our nau on then we do
have all the actions and the bot can
execute right so this is a closed list
as well you need to define them
beforehand in this case it's just utter
answers right so we do have a couple of
response templates here
don't move that around and the bot can
predict to like respond with these
messages to the user yeah so I mean I
think you do mean something else but so
action listen always stops when the user
writes something new right as soon as
the user write something shoots a
message at the bot the bot will start
predicting again maybe what you mean is
users that like split their messages
into multiple parts yeah so that is not
too easy what you can do is and you
should probably do that before sending
the message to the bot you can just wait
for one or two seconds all right giving
the user more time because it's hard to
detect when the user is done with his
typing right some platforms will give
you some indication right so they will
tell you okay the user still typing in
that case you just collect the data and
then process it as one message for
example or process it multiple messages
bar-like as one large block yeah that's
kind of the approach the best is
obviously if the platform you're using
provides you with some information if
the user is still in putting stuff okay
yeah so we cut our utter templates here
which are kind of the responses our bot
is going to send back to the user
now we're gonna write them to our file
and yeah we can actually which allows
visualize our training data which is
easy so it's just greed utter greed and
done and let's train that really simple
model here and to do so we're creating
an agent so this is how we call it a bot
that gets trained and is trained later
on and what you can see here is that we
feed in our domain files so kind of what
our bot is supposed to handle as well as
a list of policies and these policies
really are just
machine learning models or in the case
of the memorization policy is just a
large list of remembered training data
and you can add more and more policies
here and ball well we will add one more
in a minute and all of these policies
kind of do this prediction and then the
one with the largest probability wins so
that's how we decided you could also do
different approaches day of selecting
the most confident one or the one that
responds first like and then we load our
training data here in our stories and
both will train our board for 400
airports as I've heard you've learned a
couple hours ago what that means so
we'll look at each training example 400
times which is not we don't have a lot
of training data we do have six examples
that we're going to train our LST m1
yeah I'd reached accuracy one yeah what
a surprise so it is working it trained
them all it persisted it and what
happened in the back here is that we
created our Kerris model our LST M we
created our training data from our
stories had all their data into a
machine learning model and so there are
tens of flow model here that carries is
using trained out on 400 epochs and then
persisted out on disk right we're not
going to use it just now because there's
not really anything we can do with this
one so let's make up my magic sublime
part and a bit more training data so
what you can see here is that I now
provide let's say seven different
dialogue examples instead of just one
again now we can see ok it's greed
they're not agreed from the but then the
user says ok I'm
already great and the bot then responds
okay he's happy as well the user firms
obviously happy as well so there's a
really simple part by as you can see
this is how we we define our training
data and if the user responds with mood
unhappy and as in this case we will do
something else right we will do a to
cheer up instead of utter happy it
really depends on on the context and
response from the user so let's again
write that to file and then visualize
that and as you can see it's getting
more complex it's not a very simple use
case but as you can see user can shoot
different initial messages at our about
you can directly say goodbye it's
goodbye or you can start with greeting
and then bought a screeching back and
then here's our actual fork we want to
design around right use this happy or
unhappy and depending on that we do
different dialogue paths or you can see
interesting things like that one like
the mood of firm and yet were happy so
you can actually infinitely many times
say the firm's yeah this again mmm a
very good question so this is not the
train model this is just visualizing the
training data this is just showing us
what the training data looks like so
which kind of different dialogue paths
are persisted in their training data
files it's not the actual model but you
could actually do something similar with
the train model like kind of feeding the
training data into the model seeing what
it predicts and then like drawing it and
that's a similar way but right now this
is really just visualizing yeah yeah
exactly yeah you could you could build
the state machine out of that this is
true but then again there are cases in
here that are not handled right so for
example the the boss says utter happy in
this case and now the user says moot
deny for example it's not mapped in that
state machine here
and you will always have these cases
right and you will have more and more
cases to largely remain yets and your
more competitive wrong it's yeah so this
is really just a trainee data
visualization I'll change the same model
friggin 400f okay done
okay now we can actually load our model
because now I want to actually chat with
our bot and see if it actually learned
these stories but we've told it and this
command is going to load our language
model right as an interpreter from the
model directory that we've used persist
our initial language model and it's
going to load our dialogue model as well
and then we have this little snippet
that allows us so this is kind of my
chat window now it's like pretty
rudimentary way of inputting like
chatting with my bot and it's not as
cool as Facebook because cannot show me
any images but it works at least right
so it can now send messages and I'll get
answers from the boss so as you can say
hi hi you mind wait okay carry on
all right let's say hi again
how are you alright so let's try that
first and everything to our pizza and
our eyes there so I'm not so well so now
it's trying to lighten my mood and
asking me to the health
yes I agree Karen right so we can see
that but learn to like reffered use the
training data it has learned and yeah we
can put it in pizza here and it looks
like how are you I can't do it again
interesting interesting move so in that
case it probably recognized that
something like I'm not so well or
something like that and so I say lighten
my mood yeah but what if the butt
doesn't get what the message means that
let's try to handle that and we can
actually do that to some extent so as I
said it's a hard problem to hand these
out of scope messages but one good
indication is the confidence we get back
from the classifier it depends on the
model and some models don't unbell
calibrated but the more data you have
usually helps there so let me add that
here so what we're going to do is we're
going to create a fallback policy which
basically says if the intent confidence
is too low or if the action confidence
is too low stop predicting and stop
doing what you want to do and instead
use a predefined action and we do have
one does exactly fit that case which is
utter unclear all right so kind of if we
don't get exactly what the user means
we're gonna attract you right there so
let's put that in here at random and we
also need to put in some fresh shows
that we're gonna use so these are kind
of probabilities so if the the
prediction probability from the models
is below that value then we're gonna use
our fallback and we do you have one for
NAU as well and I tried it zero six no
six random values no no question okay
maybe the question might be how do you
get these values it's a really good
question
and one good way to do it is take a look
at your NAU training data for the NAU
threshold what we've done in the past is
kind of use your test data let your
model predict on that test data collect
all the confidences and then based on
that plot these confidences see where
kind of the threshold is for wrong
predictions correct predictions that
gives you a good indication of what
fresher you can use there I didn't do
that I just picked it randomly yeah if
you get stuck that usually means that
this input window is still open and it's
I've stopped here because otherwise it
will not execute the other fields of the
fight notebook because we do have our
cool while true loop here okay so let's
see I guess a new model is created and
trained
okay let's see again okay extol works
okay hi how are you I'm great
okay so works let's see what Pizza does
this work boy
let's see why that is I thought the
confidence is below that but we can try
that out here Pizza are you okay oh yeah
oh this yeah for me so I did create my
policy but I did not add it to the list
so let's do that
try again yeah it's actually that
fallback policy doesn't need any
training but it still gets persisted as
part of the model and if you want to
load the model with the fallback policy
we need to retrain it what do you like
hyper parameter search or good question
no yeah yeah so we don't do it for the
lsdm we for example do it for the SVM
for a new classification for the Charis
models we usually don't do that that
because they already train kind of quite
long and it depends on your resources so
you'd usually do that in the script that
is kind of separate from Raza core which
you could do just start it collect
results start again because you can
actually define these parameters in
configuration so we can take a quick
look so this is the persisted model here
the business model folder and we can
look at for example right here this is
the persisted enter you model and you
can see here the the parameters that
model get trained on so this for example
did a hyper parameter search for the SVM
on these parameters these are the
default parameters you could change them
and then kind of experiment with your
repair meters
alright so model change for sister this
load ad and let me quickly check the
time fifteen all right let's try that
hey still works
hmm why doesn't work okay so this is
kind of a one way to handle it but as I
said it's not easy to get like this
threshold and you should it's better to
train your energy you model already to
like handle these out of scope messages
but this is one additional fallback that
you can use to get the same but mmm okay
there's one more thing I want to show
which is but how do i execute custom
code because what we've seen just now is
just uttering bed back messages but what
I actually want to do is run some custom
code how I already wrote it yeah that's
good I'm gonna save some time here
partially rooted so we're gonna create
our custom action right it needs to be a
subclass of action it needs to have a
name and needs to have a run method and
that's it right so the name is going to
be used in our training data in our
stories and so this is the name we use
to reference direction and our run
method is getting executed once our bot
predicts direction so we can actually uh
tur a message here back to the border to
the user
searching for an image whatever and then
we can fetch the image from one possible
source of random images take some photos
/ 200-300
random and no not done okay
um right so this is kind of I could do
anything in this section right now I can
call any api's can connect to databases
you could also download the image right
here and I'm just gonna not do a rep
request right now but I'm gonna do a so
called slot set event each action can
emit a couple events that modify the
dialogue State so this is used to let
your API results influence your your
dialogue predictions this used to kind
of restart the dialogue to pause the
dialogue for example if you have a
system where a human can take over the
conversation and you want to pause the
bot and your action can actually do that
by emitting these events in in its run
method and we're gonna set the slot
called image API response we're gonna
set it or we could also fetch as I said
the image here and yes no it's not
correct okay that works
we still need to define that slot in our
domain so it's something additionally we
need to do some slots let's edit here
yeah image API response and that has a
type and on feature eyes so each slot
can have a types there's lots a kind of
structured memory of the bottom you can
have slots for for the name of the user
for hits birthday for API results of
that and in our case this slot should
not influence the dialogue prediction
right so it doesn't matter if it's set
or not dialog will behave the same way
you could also use text here for example
and in that case it actually makes a
difference if the start contains about
you or not or we can also use float here
and then we'll actually use that float
and push it through to the machine
learning model so your starts can really
influence the prediction here but for
our use case we don't neither and then
in our cheer app we're gonna use that
slot value so we do have some simple
templating here for generating the
responses for these simple cases okay
should be good one more thing I also
need to add my action to the list of
available actions and because I mean I
so usually you'd need to specify them on
your path here but in ipython that's
just mean call API so we have added our
action with edit our slots but our bot
will still never predict it because it's
not part of the training data so that
action we have down here is never and
never referenced in our stories so let's
quickly do that after unhappy we first
wanted to call API a and we do have that
here as well
okay so updated our stories
strain again that did not work hopefully
yeah it really doesn't need to be
trained for 400 that box I guess yeah
but now it's done anyways okay so this
is the way to customize like what your
bot executes and realized you to execute
custom code currently thinking about
making that easy to be used from other
languages as well so kind of writing
training your bot in Python Ronnie get a
server but having your actual logic in
JavaScript right calling actions over
HTTP and just executing them and
different programming language all right
so good none yeah that didn't work good
points none
okay none is the initial oh yeah it's
good
away
okay yeah now I'm not going to list too
many talking too much time I'm gonna
figure that out later it's not doing
that might not be retrained properly
yeah
actually actually work you can view the
actual executed proper a notebook where
I didn't code but did it beforehand so
that works in there not sure what went
wrong there and we can actually evaluate
our dialogues quite similar to our NAU
evaluation and just see okay how are the
predictions performing are there any
actions in there that don't get
predicted so this actually looks good
it's our custom image API actions in
there as well okay I don't know yeah I'm
sure what went wrong there what's up
okay I'll look that up nature okay so
let's go back how much time do I still
have more body more body moves exercises
for you alright that leaves me enough
time to show another way to train the
bots and so as I said writing these
stories doesn't always work as you've
just seen right it can fail and there's
a different way to train your board
which is from actual conversations even
if you create your board initially so
kind of the user says something but does
something stupid you correct that
behavior retrain the model and hopefully
afterwards your bot performs well so let
me show you how that works in the
command line oh there we go
I've created a make file in that
repository I showed you earlier that
contains like all of these commands they
kind of call rather Cora and I'm a bit
lazy so I'm just going to use that
interact
command here that is not available here
that is true so let's remove that and
it's a bit of an issue because now I'm
running on the command line so that
action is not in scope anymore in main
which is kind of an issue just here so
let's remove that for it time beam and
just go with our original version okay
let's try again
okay what happens here is the but will
still be trained on our initial stories
right but that fire could have also been
emptied it doesn't really matter because
the idea here is that we refine the bot
while talking to it so it will tell us
what it recognized it will tell us which
actions it predicted and then we can
always decide is that correct or wrong
and this is just a simple example on the
command line but it's like how I
imagined training about in the future
not necessarily on the command line
because you would really need some UI
here so I typed hey so the bots
recognized that I say hey it got the
correct intent here it now wants to do a
tag read which is correct right so I can
say that's correct
now the bot uttered hey how are you and
now wants to listen right sounds good as
well now I can say great know what is a
great base sounds good
that's like great and now maybe I don't
want to do at you're happy right but the
intent is correct
but I want to do execute a different
actions so kind of option 2 and now I
can see here the probabilities the model
predicted yes as you can see the model
really overfilled the training data very
well so let's make sure it doesn't do
that anymore because
now adding some conflicting data there I
wanted to cheer the bot to cheer me up
anyways so let's tell the bot to do that
so it executed that action now now
predicting action listen again which is
not correct because it should ask me if
that helps as you can see it's starting
to get a bit unsure about itself so now
it wants to listen again correct user
input how did that help yes that helped
and now but set such a happy which is
correct but as you can see this allows
you to kind of while chatting with the
bot modify its behavior and kind of
train it and let's say action listen
next input may be awesome I'm not sure
where I am in the conversation just now
because of me talking but you can then
export that conversation as well kind of
use it as additional stories and then we
can just take a quick look at our file
and then we can see it just created
similar stories to what we've written in
file and just from conversations I had
at the bottom and now you can imagine
okay multiple users having chats with
the bot you recognize when the bot fails
and then you retrain it writing these
kinds of stories is still still easy but
during the training the actions aren't
actually executed but since they can
influence the training by setting slots
you need that as part of your training
there as well so if I want the bot to
actually care about a slot that my let's
say we we do have our API action here
call image API and that action now sets
a slot like we did in our image response
um URL random as you can see here if I
want that it's not to influence a
prediction I need to put it in the
training data and if you get more and
more slots that gets hard of writing by
hand and this is why I like this
interactive mode or learning directly
from your users data is better than like
readings from hand because it gets
difficult quite quickly alright let's
wrap that up research we're currently
looking at another you and creating
embedding stare I mentioned that earlier
we have really cool blog post about that
and the idea here is that it allows you
to do multi intent labels it allows you
to recognize similarities between labels
for example that the question I'm
looking for a restaurant and I'm looking
for a hotel are quite similar and in the
sense grammatically as well as vert
choice
so they these intents are similar
whether on the other hand like greed and
goodbye or maybe more dissimilar and all
of that is based on a star space paper
which is really good paper that Facebook
publish there here we can see some
strange examples we created for that so
users can combine stuff and then you'll
get multiple intents and can handle them
these multi intent cases as well in your
dialog system obviously makes things a
lot more complex but again right you can
collect the training data and modify
that later on if you really want your
about to handle these cases all right
I'm gonna skip through that a bit but as
I said there's a lot of research
resources from on our blog post that you
can use to get into details here we're
also looking at new dialog models right
making the training there even better
and here's one example from a paper
that's hopefully getting published and
accepted we'll see and we've created a
new embedding scheme here which is also
based on star space a similar model but
using a neural Turing machine there in
the middle
so if you're interested in that there's
gonna be paper but pretty soon why do we
do that so why do we create new models
we want to generalize better between
domains right so I've showed you how to
create training data for one domain now
you can go collect more training data
for your domain but what if you created
a great part for hotel reservations and
now you want to expand that bot to
restaurant reservations right it would
be good to like reuse some knowledge
from the one domain for the the other
domain and as long as they share some
information like what you want to know
from the user actually you can share
that information between the stories and
this is for or new models allow allow
you to do okay since I'm already bit
over time I'm not going to go into the
extensions in detail but you can combine
these machine learning models for fluid
based systems right for some things
rule-based systems are really good right
for example for normalization as I said
for who they system is really easy to
say okay tomorrow what's the current
date okay this is the ISO date we can
take a quick look at the duckling
parents what they implement here is
basically just a large reg X pricing
system so here's a reg X for half an
hour which is 1/2 an hour half an hour
whatever and that creates 30 minutes
right and there are a lot of these
different regular expressions here to
convert certain expressions into
structured information and for some
entities that we he is useful and it's
really good to combine that with your
attorney where's my presentation
ah yeah it's not full screen anymore
great doesn't matter yeah we've seen the
Spacey built-in models so it's also good
to like rely on these built-in models
and we also provide some functionality
to to do form filling right so there's a
really common task we've seen how many
people do you need for your restaurant
table when do you want to book it like
these slot filling tasks there you have
certain pieces of information that you
need before you can actually submit that
information to your api and we've
integrated that form filling parts in
rather to make that easier okay some
final thoughts before I close up I made
that point a couple of times during talk
what we want to achieve is really that
you're able to retrain the board based
on new data which is that big benefit of
using machine learning instead of
web-based system so new data comes in
you correct that training data right
create new energy annotations create new
dialogue stories retrain your models
real able you're collected data right
let's say you've collected a thousand
messages from users you've returned your
models you want to real able them to
then see ok which of them are still
wrong and then you can use that improve
model to continuously improve your bot
there's still a lot of open challenges
right we've talked about them handling
out of vocabulary words so words that
you don't have any word vectors for or
multi-language
entity recognition right so these malls
are usually trained on a single language
or combining miles of the dialogue
models from different domains how how do
you decide which dialogue model is able
to handle next message that's tough all
right you'll get the slides there's a
couple good reads for rainy day first
one's really good it's from a mining who
is really famous for a natural language
processing and he's
comparing okay how does deep learning
fit into the natural language processing
domain which is like more into this
feature creation and finding out best
features for machine learning models and
all of these are very interesting reads
so take some time there Sophia for take
home all really important their
techniques to handle small data sets
because you'll start small when creating
a new bot right you don't have a lot of
data and really providing models for
that that can handle it's really
essential but then once you have
collected more and more data you want to
scale these models and create better
models that actually can handle the
complexity of your dialogues and it's
always good to combine that with
traditional programming and rules right
we haven't done that in our example but
as I said right you don't need to rely
on machine learning for everything and
should really go back to traditional
programming where necessary
right there end-to-end models for
example that also predict API calls
right and the parameters for that but
it's really difficult and you need a lot
of training data for that so just avoid
that very possible and Bend flowcharts
first just for showing your training
there that's good but for everything
else that's good yeah thanks a lot for
attention for participation and yeah
hope to see you around
[Applause]